gender expression is different gender
expression deps on last all the science
last 100 years has shown in boys who who
experience gender dysphoria between two
and three
85% of them simply grow up to be gay oh
I love that you're saying
this don't interrupt and be rude the
other five you don't think that
dismissing an entire group of people
being rude and then there are one or
two% the transgender dysphoria persists
into adulthood at the age of four child
is not going to know what emotional
attraction Means versus physical
attraction children do get crushes e e
they're teaching these kids emotional
and physical attraction at four people
are pedophiles these people are
pedophiles